the Joe Rogan experience yeah I don't
think pain pills are good to take I've
dabbled but yeah I know how addictive it
is Jordan Peterson just checked himself
into rehab
why yeah whoa whoa whoa for what he got
on an anti-anxiety lonappan anxiety
medication because his wife is that's
heavy you know with his wives dealing
with heavy cancer like liver cancer yeah
yeah and she's been going through
operations and apparently she's doing
well now and he's trying to get off of
this stuff and when he tried to get off
of it he had such a horrible withdrawal
that he is according to his daughter
it's on the news yeah he had to check
himself in so he it's an anti-anxiety
medication apparently that's how it's
used some one of the ways it's used but
it's a strong one hold on opinion it
sounds like a drug that people take I
mean my friends took that in high school
then that's no xanax that's like Episode
II what is it like I it was just like it
shut you down it was you know just is
that one of the ones that ring on you're
ruined to take people off a heroin
that's methadone but isn't there another
one wasn't that isn't Kalan open one of
those ones that they use is therapeutic
I just know people take it
recreationally and going okay do yeah
come on pimples you like a whole two or
that's ketamine yeah but people take it
too they it'll [ __ ] yeah as far yeah
like two beers and you're and one of my
friends tried to jump out of a window on
it like it is bad news I think he was
just really devastated his wife was
essentially dying right in front of his
eyes and so he probably couldn't handle
it so he got on some medication well
he's he's one of those guys like uh he's
tough as a bull it'll be fun but then
you know everybody's human well also I
think he's wise enough to understand his
physical limitations and I I don't have
never experienced real withdrawal I mean
I was experimenting withdrawal but never
like a real same opiate withdrawal
apparently it's [ __ ] horrible hey it
might actually be a smart thing to check
yourself you have with people that know
how to deal with it and help you through
it you know yes it's not actually it's
the same thing as klonopin it's called
clonazepam yeah okay so this is like a
street name
but a doctor prescribed it right which
is weird like oh the doctor gave him the
crack it's okay well all those pills are
beds pharmacy crack yeah that's what
fentanyl is right a fentanyl
out-of-control panic disorder and
anxiety and seizures
it can cause paranoid or suicidal
ideation and hair memory judgment and
coordination come but this makes sense
for a lot of people I know combining
with other substances particularly
alcohol can slow breathing and possibly
lead to death Jesus doctor needed doctor
doctor prescription Tara
hook it up dude I can't I just can't
need some kalam pin but you never take a
percocet and just laid in the pool no
baby either a percocet or a vicodin once
at one of my knee surgeries yeah and I
was like this is terrible oh wow that's
good that's a blessing you don't want to
like it it made me really stupid yeah my
brain was so numb I was like I'd rather
be in pain Wow ignorant and volscian or
an anti Santa epileptic drug as well huh
mmm
that means it's strong so it must do a
bunch of different [ __ ] yeah I also used
to treat panic attacks so you must have
been having panics yeah I mean if she's
your best time of your life you know you
were an embattled professor fighting
against social justice warriors and in
some sort of crazy law that was going to
enforce a hundred and ninety eight
thousand gender pronouns and he was like
hey this is crazy let's stop stop stop
yeah I remember that and then he becomes
a national celebrity and people fight
him and they're angry with him but also
people are realizing the extent of the
chaos that's going on these universities
where these they/them Zinser demand
these pronouns these nonsensical made-up
pronouns and he was like you can't
enforce speech you can't remorse people
is like you understand understand what
this is and where this goes yeah it
leads to tyranny right everybody thought
he was being like really exaggerating
and over the top then as times gone on
you realize like oh no he just saw all
this he saw this coming he was right
like people are radicalized and I think
there and it's about a lot of it is
about compliance they were able to
comply I want you to comply with my new
pronouns
[Applause]